yeah hello my name is Robert pusu and
I'm studying physics at the University
of rostock and my question to you what
was your motivation to to work in your
actually field so at the beginning I was
attracted by the subject of my PhD so
testing some suggestion by the Nobel
Prize navion malt he suggested that the
spin of the electron can influence
strongly the conviction in ferromagnetic
metals so I could show in my PhD that
this was true that I can find some
materials with a strong influence of the
spin in on the connection then after the
pH team so I observe our ID on effects
you also to the effect of the spin on
the electrical conduction and my
motivation was also was all way to to
test my ideas and to explore a new
direction of a Saoirse always I try to
avoid the action of Michelle what too
many people are walking and I prefer to
two of my ideas my play with my
imagination and two so explore all the
new fields of research